Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning podcast
and Ah, I'm just checking in on
you. What's going on? How are you?
How's your week going? Oh, you're
having a rough one. We'll, it's okay.
It's almost over. It's Thursday.
You know, don't you hate your boss?
A little less on Thursday.
Hey, comes in. Hey,
go over there and do what I say.
And you're like, oh, chubby cheeks.
You know, you love to say that to them.
Just grab his muffin top
doll. What veto do shop doing?
Okay.
Did you technically
get fired for that? He,
all you have to do is just when you're
going in for the disciplinary meeting,
he just, you know, you just stay
in the pocket. Just be luck.
I have no problem doing what this man
says, but I can't fight the fact that,
yeah, I think he's adorable.
I mean look at him once you want to go
up there and give him a little, you know,
oh, we'll put on a tie today. Yeah,
that's a fucking great way to
get your ass fired. I don't know.
What if everybody does it though?
You know the strength in numbers.
Is this like a Sally field movie?
Should I be fucking standing
up holding a sign? Yeah. Union.
Right? Still brave. It was so
brave what she did in the mind.
Um, is there any word more
overused in the entertainment,
specifically the movie acting business
than brave Jesus fucking Christ.
Has any actor ever looked
up that fucking word?
The way you went out there with that band,
Dan? It was such a brave performance.
Yeah. Jesus Christ. You know, just go.
When did you go over to craft service
and get yourself something that has yoga
in it? You fucking stupid,
you know, courageous, brave,
important. This was a story
that needed to be told.
Okay.
Oh my God, those fucking award shows.
And it never dawns on him the irony
that everything we're wearing colluding,
what they shtick,
sweat pants and t shirt I have on right
now is all made in a sweatshop by some
crying child at fucking three in
the morning and Che in n whatever,
Honduras or some shit. Right.
And they're all up there acting
like they give a fuck about people.
It's like you don't, you
want to go with their,
you want fucking Ruth buzzy or whatever
fucking name is to say what you're
wearing. Looks good. You know,
and then you want to win the shiny
thing and you want to cry and thank your
mother and pretend you're down to earth
and go back to you fucking infinity
pool. That's what you really want to do.
Right. Do a little fucking, you know,
have Jack Nicholson come over, do
some blow off your titties. You know,
if you're a guy, a, you know, who
knows what you want to do out here.
I didn't want to talk in about, you know,
I'm just having one of those scatterbrain
days and I went to bed early last
night. You know, as I always do,
whenever I go on tour with [inaudible]
and Bart, nick, I think all of us,
like for the next three days, have to
like dry out and try to get about, oh,
about 14 hours sleep. Um,
so yeah, I'm off the booze.
I'm off to cigars, you know,
the usual fucking thing. I'm all
over the goddamn place. And um,
oh fuck. You know what? Somebody told
me yesterday, here's a new thing.
All right,
how fucking in this fucking world that
just keeps getting more and more creepy.
You know, that whole big brother
thing, but blah, blah blah, blah, blah.
And then people are saying, oh, big
brother turns out it's actually us. Um,
and it is, it is because we were
just keep going along with this shit.
Yeah.
Listen, his belt,
just tell the fucking story before you
go on your stupid little rant here.
All right, so buddy, my
tells me another day, right?
He a that a friend of his came over to
do some work on his house because a,
if you own a house, you're constantly
trying to fix it so it doesn't fall down.
That's what they don't tell you. You know,
when they show the commercial and the
real estate commercials, you know, Oh,
white picket fence, golden retriever,
you watch had six kids and
she's still hot, right?
Isn't that the other song goes anyways.
And they're all running around there.
They're uh, you know, ridiculously green,
front yard played Frisbee, you know,
the dog's not trying to eat
anybody. Your wife's laughing.
The kids are all good looking
right. Everything's fine, right?
Nobody has a list. Nobody has, you
know, fucking jealousy issues. You know,
guy doesn't have dad bod
basically crushing it.
They can and you just look at it and
you're like, you know what, if I, if I,
you know, if I buy a house, you know,
I know I'm not going to look like that,
but is that the mood I'm going to be
in? It's like a drug, right? So anyways,
he fucking, um,
he fucking has this guy's
buddy come over to some work.
So he goes to pay him and as all good
guys do, well, you don't need to pay him.
You don't even pay me. And he's like,
no, come on, I want to pay it. Nah,
I'll tell you I'm not gonna accept it.
Just take the fucking money. Right.
They had to do a sketch like that with
too polite friends and ends up in a knife
fight.
One person finally kills the guy and then
fucking stuffs the money in his mouth.
Should they do a sketch like that? I
think they should. Um, anyway, so he goes,
so finally the guy goes, you don't have
to pay me, just get me a case of beer.
So the guy goes, fine.
So the closest place that at
a little bit Owlette was cvs.
So it goes down to cvs.
He buys the fucking case of beer and the
lady behind the lady behind the counter
goes, do you have an id? And he's
looking at it like, bitch, I'm 50.
And he goes, do you really think I,
you know, you don't think I'm of age?
She goes, I need to swipe your
license. And she, he goes for what?
She goes, oh, um, basically
for health insurance purposes,
they record, you know, if you
drink or not. And if you drink,
your premium goes up because
you're a drinker. Now,
what the fuck this cds give a shit about
rat and everybody out who's a fucking
booze face out there. Right?
Cause you know what it is the money that
they're gonna fucking be able to, to,
to knock up, you know on
your premium to pump it up.
CVS gets, it gets a little kickback.
That's how it fucking works.
It's like when I drive you
to fucking amazon.com right?
If you go through my website,
they give me a little aid.
Thanks for sending some business our
way. Break you off a couple of honeys.
Right.
Okay.
But I'm not costing you any more
money. I'm the hero with this.
I don't cost you any more money.
Whether you go directly to Amazon,
if you go to my website,
it doesn't make any difference to
me and I'm mostly not ratting out.
What I'm trying to say here is I am
a way better person than cvs. No,
I'm fucking with you. Look we're all
trying to make money out here but that's,
that's really, it's fucking ridiculous.
I actually always try and look at it
from the insurance company side of it.
Cause you know God damn well everybody
goes in there and lies these smoke,
you know, you drink. No,
I mean maybe I'll have
a beer, I don't know,
on the 4th of July to support the troops.
[inaudible]
do you engage in any a drug activity?
If, I mean food's at drugs
self, technically yes, but
I mean that other style,
no, I would do you have
unprotected sex with prostitutes?
Listen, I got a phone call. Can I,
can I take this? You know, you know,
you know that deal. You
lie your fucking ass off.
You're going to get life insurance.
You lie your fucking ass off. Right?
So on one side,
I actually have empathy from insurance
companies because I understand that
aspect of it.
Provided they ever fucking paid
out any goddamn money remotely.
Like they said they were gonna you
know the deal, you pay for insurance,
they say you're covered and you
say to them, hey, if this happens,
am I going to be covered if I, I got the,
uh, the old stuff, the tow insurance.
So if I wake up in the morning, I stub
my toe. Okay, I'm a man, I can take it,
but if I break my fucking toe, okay,
and you know my job is to
skip on stage every night.
If I have to take a night off,
can you, can you kick me the,
you know the fucking $25 feature
spot money. Can you kick that to me?
They're like, absolutely. I
go hide. So if I break my toe,
step my toe in my house and Co,
absolutely you're covered right now.
What happens? You stub your toe, you
break it, you fucking call them up.
They're like, okay, I've got
to send it through the Ya,
you're not getting paid quadrant quadrant
of the fucking insurance company.
Then they come back and what do they do?
They'll give you like fucking 13 bucks
instead of the 25 they owed you nine or
13 between 25 doesn't seem
like a lot money. Right?
But you just ratchet that up there. Right?
But if they owed LG two 50
they only gave you one 30 what?
They owed you 25 grand and
they only gave you fucking six.
That's what the fuck they do.
They are in the business of taking your
fucking money and buying themselves a
yacht and fucking banging Victoria's
secret models in the ass while I'm looking
at the next year's model of
fucking uh, yeah, that's,
that's what they're in the business of.
They are not in the business
of fucking help it people,
they're in the business
of taking your money,
telling you that you're going to be
covered and then when you go, dude,
what the fuck? Right? They go, yeah,
go fuck yourself cause we got more
money taken a leave it. Right.
And what should happen is
like, you know, when, uh,
do you remember the mighty heroes when
they would send out that little signal
and they'd all fucking tour
diaper man and strongman,
they'd all turn into some or was it
Batman out fucking remember when everybody
was insured by that company should
go at those cons and be like, dude,
what the fuck? I thought you
said this guy was covered.
This is what you're doing to him. You're
going to do it to all of us. Right.
I'm going back to the Sally field
thing. You know what the problem is,
is nobody likes their neighbor. You know,
you look across that and you look at the
car you drive and you look at his wife
either don't understand what
he bought or you want it.
There's never a middle
ground like, yeah, you know,
I'm pretty much on par with this guy and
I get my ego can handle living across
from him. You're either going to
resent them or not understand them.
So then when he gets fucked out of
money, he's telling you the story.
You're sitting there nodding your
head, acting like you don't like it,
but you hate to admit it. There's a part
of your soul that's getting filled up,
isn't it? Admit it. You know
like your neighbors, right.
It really came down to it.
Don't you want a house as big as
your house and your neighbors?
Wouldn't it be great if they
just weren't there anymore?
Somehow there was wasn't
any like forensics and they
could figure it out that
you a hastened his demise
and took over his house.
Just added a fucking hallway
between your house and his right.
Then the whole other
house is yours, right?
So when your wife and kids are driving
you nuts, you just say, listen,
Daddy's going over to his other life.
I'll be back when I can deal with you.
And everybody just
looks at you like those,
that family in that real estate commercial
just smiling and waving, being like,
yeah, it's fine. Don't worry about
it. Right? Then you go in there,
right and said anything you want,
you've got booze, you got cigars,
you know you got, I'm a
sue slash a fucking whore.
They want to have that the timeout
room for a married guy. You know,
and I know what you ladies to tick. Well,
why don't they have a time out room
for women? Ain't no what I say. Well,
why don't you come up with it? The world
doesn't know you're around a drinks.
Okay? And goddammit, you got
debt, multitask and pray.
Once you sit down with a couple other
prods, what would be in your room?
You know a bunch of shit
that makes you live longer.
See if you notice what the guy, everything
I said would slowly fucking kill me.
The Bose, the cigars, the
horse, all of it just,
it just eats away at your soul
in your fucking liver, right?
Women would go on the first,
one of the first things they probably
want is like the most beautiful fucking
tub they ever could find. They could
take a nice fucking bath. You know what?
They're crazy little fucking soaps, right?
They have a whole spa day and they'd have
a friend that they could sit down and
get all of that resentment out of their
heart with someone who can actually
listen to it. They
download all of that shit.
You just totally clean up their soul
before they go into the next room and get
fucking bang by Brad Pitt. You know,
whoever the fucking Jake Gyllenhaal
guy is nowadays. Who is it?
Is it Justin Bieber? Has he become
a man yet? He's in his 20s. Right?
He's riding the wave out of teen
idol. Them slowly become an a man,
right? As long as he
doesn't remake blue lagoon,
I think that kid's going to
be all right. Um, anyways,
my Jesus Christ, these 12 minutes of
your life, you'll never get back. Um,
you know what? Today's about
everybody. Today's not about you.
Today's not about me. Today's
not even about America.
You know what today's about.
Today's about the Boston Bruins
versus the Detroit Red Wings.
That's what it's all about. Okay?
It's funny that they play all these
fucking games and it can come down to one
God damn game for those of
you who don't watch hockey,
all right? Which is kind of me. I
just pay attention to it because I've,
are you fucking content once? Can I pass
whatever worked the first fucking time?
You know, they're always like, you
know, that's not secure enough. Well,
it's like, it's so fucking secure.
I can't do it on one time while
I'm still on a fucking podcast.
Jesus fucking Christ. Anyways,
they play all these goddamn games.
Let me get back into the nicest
soothing tone that I had earlier. Um,
they play all these fucking games, 80
goddamn games, whatever the hell it is.
And you would think that, you know, by
now everything would be all sorted out,
right? Let's go to the playoff picture.
The playoff picture. Here we
go. I didn't need a picture.
I need a brow to play playoff
bracket. I can't read that shit.
Bracket. Challenge the fucking standings.
That's how, that's how old I am. I think.
I feel like if I just yell at
a website, I'll do what I want.
Um, all right so the,
so the fucking red wings have
93 points. Oh they got 93.
That's right. Cause they, that's right.
Cause they beat the fucking filthy
flyers. All the flyers needed that one.
The flyers needed that one. For some
reason I root for the Philadelphia Flyers.
I like them. They know what I mean.
I know that they'd been dirty
and fought knowledge ship.
He can't tell me it wasn't
entertaining. You know,
Ron Hextall come and flying out of the
net cause he's pissed that he lost the
Stanley Cup finals. I've
always enjoyed that shit. Um,
I don't like the offense,
but I liked it. Team.
Uh, but you know, Philly fans work at,
you're not liking making you not like
them. So they did the job with me.
I don't like them. Um, so
anyways, so Detroit beat them.
So as of right now, Detroit has 93 points.
Philadelphia has 91. The Bruins have 91,
but for whatever fucking
reason, I guess head their head,
maybe we or we have a game
at hand. I don't know what,
we're still under the fucking bar
line. So basically tonight, tonight,
the red wings I think could solidify,
let's see, I have two more. Get look
to choice. Detroit wants to an idea.
They're either in or they've
totally fucking, you know,
they'd have to basically put me
in net to not make the playoffs.
But if the Bruins,
when we will go up two points on
the Philadelphia flyers and a,
this is the biggest fucking game.
They're all big games this week,
but this is a for [inaudible]. This
is a big one this week. And uh,
and other Redwings haven't been
the greatest in the past few years,
but they got enough guys left.
Oh, and by the way, I want to say,
shout out to that fucking Twitter cunt.
That fucking laughed at me when I said,
you know, Carolina fucking, I feel
like they always get the best of us.
And he was saying like, oh,
we're the Bruins are six. So,
and to the last fucking tie, well, you
know something, I never forgot that game.
Seven in 2009 when they came
back and they fucking beat us.
And just times, every time there's a
big game like that, you know, something,
they always beat us. And what happens?
We play those kinds. And what happened?
What happened? They ended
up beating us in a shooter,
but we did get one point then Christ. Um,
I think you do right? Don't
you get one point that I don't,
every time I turn it on,
they fucking change the rule.
Now they're doing three on three in the
overtone, which I like, but you know,
it makes me feel like I blacked
out for five years. So anyways,
we gotta to win that game
tonight. Um, and I was hoping, uh,
Detroit would look a little more
tired than they did last night,
but they totally looked like
they were on their fucking game.
The one thing we got going
is it's back to back. Um,
which usually during the
season you'd have a let down,
but there's too much at stake. So I think
this is going to be a tough game. And,
uh, um, I don't know. My
heart says we're gonna win,
but I don't know. We'll see.
It's been tough for us lately.
All right, let's, uh, oh, and by the way,
the amount of people that hate the fucking
Bruins, I, hey, it's like four white.
We want one cup in 40 years. The
fuck is your problem. You know,
I love when our fucking teams sit
there and they act like, you know,
this team's dirty and
this team has excuses,
but our team's fucking
squeaky clean. You know,
I see the pieces of shit on my team,
just the way I see them on your team,
you know,
I see your fucking coaches screaming
and yelling anytime anybody touches your
players. And then when your
players touch somebody else there,
I don't give a fuck. Everybody does that.
It's called being an
immature cunt. You know,
welcome to the party. Have a seat.
Can I get you a drink? All score big,
everybody. A little bit of advert
to Miss Smith's million since uh,
you're paying too much for tickets
between all the mockups and last minutes.
Convert convenience charges,
even printed home fees.
They really charge you to print tickets
at home. It's fucking unbelievable.
All those types of charges, I'm telling
you, that just ends up, you know,
that's just somebody standing
in a four year of a house.
He can't afford just reign
and money down on prostitutes.
You ever watch American greed? That's
that. It gradually all adds up to that.
All right, you end up paying
courtside prices for nosebleed seats.
Score big.com is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live
tickets go on sold? Do you know that?
And did you know that there's a
place to get seats at huge savings?
It's called score. Big Dotcom score.
Big works directly with
your favorite teams.
And artists to get their unsold
seats at unpublished prices.
Only at ScoreBig Dotcom.
Can you name a ticket price
and be guaranteed to pay
below box office up to 60%
off. Here's all you got to
do. One number one. Oh No. Ah,
go to score. Big Dotcom.
And finally event and seats.
You want to dose to like this
little bilingual shit for you here.
Huh? Make an offer with score.
Biggs name a ticket price feature three.
Oh Jesus Trois. And what is
it? We'll note those trays.
Get an instant answer and save
up to 60% on your tickets.
Now I realize I've never seen a
French referee count somebody on Ah,
the quasi cut saying seasick.
Queet NERF DCE Finney. Um, no
surprise fees and free shipping.
Wait, uh, did I say get an instant answer
and save up to 60% of your tickets?
No surprise fees and free shipping.
Just unbeatable prices on great seats.
And when you're in great seats,
you actually enjoy the game or the
show all the more next time. Yeah.
Cause you as your hammer telling
everybody you'd be that guy.
How much did you pay? Next time
you go and see any game or show,
go to score big first and
see how much you can save.
Go to score big.com right
now. Click on the microphone,
enter the Promo Code Bar and you'll
save an extra $20 off your first ticket
price. That scorebig.com
Promo Code Bar, high score,
big.com Promo Code burpee you are are.
Um, I'm at one time went to a game,
the guy was like, hey, how'd you get
tickets? It's like, oh, scout them out,
how much you pay. And I answered him and
he's like, yeah, we got these for this.
It's like, go here. Does that make you
feel better? You tight. Fuck, I couldn't.
Every once in a while it's like, you
know, just in those moments you're like,
why did I just let another
adult do that to me? You know,
and you hate yourself.
Then you're a little surly to your
wife and next thing you know, yeah,
she's not banging you a
pole in branch. You know,
you probably spend more time with your
bedsheets than anything else you own.
You really shouldn't
skimp on your bedding,
but most people do because
great sheets are very expensive.
Thanks to Boll and branch,
that's not the case anymore.
And when you spend the big bucks on
sheets with super high thread count,
you think you're getting the best.
But what you're really getting is
marketing Mumbo jumbo. Oh my God, dude,
am I really have to read
five paragraphs about sheets?
Thread counts have nothing to do with
quality and don't get me started on
so-called Egyptian cotton. The
fuck is that. That just came,
just just the name of a plant
grown in Pakistan, in China.
Uh, well, you know,
it didn't back in the date and the
they'll no white man bring his ships over
there for all the fucking spices and
sheets. Isn't that what happened? Um,
you value your, you value your
sleep. Don't put words in my mouth,
but you know what? You're right.
Instinctive son of a pitch.
But whenever you head
to a department store,
you're forced to pay a huge markup for
sheets that aren't even that great.
Boll and branch sheets are
different. First of all,
let me cross my legs during
this part. First of all,
sit down and let me tell you a story.
You can only get them at Boland,
branch.com so you know you're paying
for quality sheets and not for overhead.
And quite frankly,
they're the most comfortable sheets in
the world they made with the entirely
organic cotton and a night sleeping on
Boll and branch sheets makes your day so
much better. Three US presidents
sleep on Boll and branch.
Well how do you know that? Isn't
there like a security issue? Jesus.
How filthy or Bill Clinton's
that fucking animal a,
these are people who can afford to sleep
on any brand of sheets in the world and
they even choose bold and they
even choose boll and branch.
How can they afford to sleep
on any brand in the world?
They only make 400 grand a year
before taxes. Oh that's right.
Cause then they give speeches for
fucking 500 grand and night to everybody.
You put them in office. So they wash
their bribe money. Oh, shut up bill. Okay,
here we go. They even cut out all the
middlemen, department store markups,
which by the way are up to 800% so you're
getting amazing luxurious sheets for a
couple of hundred bucks. Boll
and branch is so confident. Oh,
this is all capital letters.
Boll and branch is so confident.
You'll love their sheets that they'll
let you try them completely risk free for
30 nights, jerk off on them, fuck on
them, sleep on them, drool on them.
We don't give a shit. Uh, it gets
even better. If you order right now,
they'll give you 50% off a set
of sheets plus free shipping.
Just go to boll and branch.com that's B
o l l and branch.com and use the Promo
Code Burger. That's, that's right.
Okay. She just said, is that right?
That is right.
Get $50 off ish off a sheet set
immediately by going to be o,
L L and B r a n c h.com. And
using the Promo Code Bar.
All right, mercifully, here's the
last one. Legal Zoom. Number one,
uno. Uh,
a reliability more than a million people
who have already trusted legal zoom to
start their business and
corporations, LLCs, nonprofits,
dbs and more using legal zoom to get
started the right way. Number two,
the dose experience. You can
account on legal zoom experience.
You can count on a legal
zoom oh experience period.
You can count on legal
zoom for all the details.
They've been helping all types of business
owners for 15 years. Number three,
helpful support.
They have the right people standing by
ready to help you with your questions.
All based in the U S number four
of Jesus Christ. Legal advice.
Legal Zoom is in a law firm,
so they built a network of
independent attorneys in 48 states.
You'll get answers to your legal
questions and they can review supplier
contracts, contracts, employment laws,
and help with most of the day to
day situations that pop up. Do.
This is how you know these guys are on
point is because they need to be on point
and you need people who can't
even write fucking exciting copy.
This copy is so fucking dry.
You know that these guys going to dot
all the i's and cross all the t's.
Even the ladies, even the
ladies. You know what I mean?
I don't mean just when I
say guys, I mean everybody.
Okay,
well that's a sexist term. Well I don't
give a fuck. All right. And finally,
number five, no surprise here.
Legal zoom pro, no surprises. Sorry.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency
with upfront pricing and customer
views with a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
A make the smart choice for your
business@legalzoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter birth
to checkout to save even more.
That's legal zoom.com
right? And it's over.
It's over. All right.
You guys want some drum node shit
before I get off the podcast,
wind it down here.
You guys know that song by sting
love is stronger than justice.
A lot of people sleep on stink, you
know, cause he comes out all yoga it up,
still looking like he could bang a 22
year old and every he's like, oh man,
that's fucking a baby boomer
elevator music. Well, I like it.
I like it. Um, is a song on a,
what does that 10 summers tails as a
song? Love is stronger than justice.
This is some drum nerd shit.
Now I've listened to that song at least
a thousand fucking times and I thought
it was like, I don't know if it's bar
a measure. I don't know. I say it,
I thought you counted seven twice
then you counted four, four,
then three, four and then seven.
Right. Can I actually play this here?
Why don't I play the fucking song?
I'll show you. So this is some fucking,
this is the dumbest Shit I think
I'm going to do. Oh, that's right.
I can't play it on my fucking laptop
for whatever fucking reason. Um,
yeah.
Cause I have too many things signed into
fucking iTunes and then my old shit,
I can't, I don't remember
the password for.
Okay.
I thought the big brother was
looking at me through the camera.
Can't they fucking see?
Can't they see that?
Is that it's me. Let me see if
I can fucking play this for you.
Okay.
All right. So I always thought that
this is how you counted it, right?
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven one, two, three, four, one,
three, one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, one.
Right. It finally dawned on me today
that when I was counting four, four,
and then three for four plus three is
seven so you can count the whole fucking
thing and she's seven
the one here we go.
Oh, one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, three, two, three, four,
five, six, seven 43 four, five,
six, seven, one.
So it's really four fucking measures
is seven and I was like, Oh,
the plain who fucking Shevon twice.
Then they go for four Dan, it's three,
four days back to seven. All right.
It's like no stupid that just
making it sound like it's in four,
four and then all of a sudden they
lop off one beat and you're like, oh,
what the fuck? But back to one again,
which really is the layman's
term for still being at seven.
I learned that while walking at pit bull
picking up dog shit this morning. Huh?
What the fuck have you been doing? Um,
so anyways, um,
how the fuck do I get
out of this? You know,
in defense to me as much as I also
loved that album, that fucking,
I don't all the new shit that
I listened to. Uh, you know,
as I watched the Grammy's and I was like,
I am downloading everything that
wings some Grammy's here, right?
Not Everything, but you know,
so I basically, I downloaded a,
I can't remember Alabama
shakes the weekend.
Leonardo DiCaprio. What's a fuck set
guys? That rapper who won everything?
I can never remember. Kendrick
Lamar, right? I downloaded all,
all this shit that, and I like all of
this stuff. I got to tell you that like,
uh, the one that actually I, I
liked the best is the weekend.
I just think it's a fucking, it's
an unbelievable album. Unbelievable.
You're an amazing voice.
And some of the songs that he really
does sound a lot like Michael Jackson,
but not, and not even in a bad way,
just like influenced by the guy. Um,
so this morning when I walked, when
I was walking around the block,
I listened to rat round and round,
starting the day off with the
little Bobby blocks up, right?
Then I listened to that sting
song and I was thinking like, ah,
that's what I figured out. Wait a minute.
Four, three to seven. What the fuck?
Literally picking up dog shit with a big
goofy grin on my face and this fucking
beautiful woman jog by looking at me
like, is this guy excited about dog shit?
See listening to a podcast about dog
shit. Just one of those moments, you know,
and just like, yeah, whatever, you
know. Anyways. And then I was just like,
alright, I keep, as much as I keep
trying to listen to new music,
I keep going back to the shit I listened
to when I was growing up. So, um,
out of all the ones that I keep coming
back to that guy's fucking album,
I just think it's the shit. So I'm
not, I'm not 100% over the hill,
you know what I mean? And I
actually have, unbeknownst to me,
I have a college gig coming up,
which I'm very excited about.
I barely do college gigs anymore.
I don't know why, you know,
I have to keep doing college kids
cause I gotta keep my fan base being,
you know, I've got to keep getting the
next generation of people how it works.
You know, you can't,
you don't want to grow old with your
crowd and that just reminded you how old
you are. It's like I should
only think that, you know,
twice a day when I'm brushing my
teeth, you know, put the toothpaste on,
you start brushing, you look up
Jason far off. Oh it's me. You know,
I only want to feel that
twice and fill it twice
in a day. Um, but uh,
okay.
What happens is, is if you just kind
of state, you know, with your fan base,
you know, they get married, they have
kids and even if they want to come out,
they're so fucking tired. They just want
to sleep if they actually get a moment,
you know what I mean? So, uh, you got
to keep the young kids coming out.
The young kids that can't feel their
face, but they love it. Um, oh Jesus.
Alright, that's the, uh, the just
checking in for you on your podcast.
I will talk to you guys on Monday.
I hope you have a great weekend.
Your constant. Please enjoy this music
and we will say what music it is,
uh, on the Twitter,
the mm at the MMP Twitter account and um,
okay.
And a whatever. And then
you guys can all fit in.
[inaudible] play this.
Yeah. We'll have your own fucking
podcast yet. Fucking all right. See you.
Oh,
[inaudible]
depress dude, a Billy
cunt exclamation point.
I'd been listening. I've been
listening to your podcast for years.
Your deranged psychopathic perspective
reminds me I'm not the only one
shaken ladders. I don't know what
that means is this guy from Boston.
I've been listening to
the podcast for years.
You Drain psychopathic perspective reminds
me and not the only one shake and lad
his kid that still doesn't even
have any accent shaking ladders.
I don't know what that means.
Anyways, I got a problem. Yeah,
I was in Boston all last
week. So the fast ball,
the Boston accent kind of came
back. The old La, you know,
I got a problem saying that get
a job and get a julep duties.
You get a job and for those you
working on your Boston accents job,
just say like jaw.
Like I'm going to punch you in the jaw
and then B Joe up gotta get a fucking
job, you know, kills me right now
is like fucking 200. You right now.
Just muttering g self give
fucking job and your cubicle.
Okay.
I'm freaking out. Your coworkers
just mumbling, you know, fucking do
you fucking Kwok shocker. Um,
I've got a problem for years now.
I've been trapped in my
KFC and wet wipes. Okay,
that's disgusting.
I used to be a bodybuilder and actor and
a comedian with fucking prospects right
in front of me, but then adulthood
raped me in the eyes. Oh Jesus.
Could you be more dramatic?
It sounds like that fucking
chick from a sex in the city.
Crazy Bro. Broke my hat. I had,
this is the guy again, crazy broad,
broke my heart.
I had to cut away old friends and
family shutting me out of their smiles.
All right, so this is like getting
creepier with each sentence.
If you don't bring this
around in like two sentences,
am I going to abandon this?
Had a cut away from old friends and
family's shutting me out of their smiles.
Dude,
what did you do that your friends and
family decided they didn't want to be
around you anyways? I don't feel
sorry for myself or want any pity. Uh,
I just, you're not going to get any.
So good. I'm glad you don't. He goes,
I just want to know how to get out of
this. Never ending routine of demise.
Well, first of all, I would just stop
using those goth death metal words.
Yeah.
You know, demise when she got in here.
Adult rape me in the eyes.
These are like song lyrics,
you know,
depressed dude. What would be the
name of this trafficker? Barker.
I have to get wet wipes. Right? It
sounds like I can't sing like that.
Great
digital and I've got my eyes and all
these fucking kids get like wet fucking
whiplash. I'm,
I work too much in a jeweler that was
supposed to pay for my comedy career when
I don't work. I, uh, I was supposed
to wait for my comedy career when I,
when I don't work, uh, I sleep
or oh, when I don't work,
I sleep or watch endless DVDs. I'm 24
years old of what the fuck this reads.
Like you have 56, dude, he goes,
I'm tired all the time from all the
hating of the world and my body just won't
listen to the screaming
frustration in my soul. Dude,
you listen to like you
listen to progressive metal.
I'm guessing by the
words you use here, uh,
either that you played
dungeons and dragons.
I'm really not helping you depression
by shitting on you through all of this.
Um, don't worry. I'm going to give you
some sunshine here in the end here.
So I sometimes get a spark of motivation
to get back in shape and just start
writing scripts. But it only lasts
for a day or two at the most. Yeah,
exactly. And then, and then the
work comes and you have to going.
And that's what separates the people in
life who fucking work and in make it.
And those who don't, you
know, everything's fun for
a couple of fucking days.
I'm going to get shredded.
I'm gonna join a boxing gym.
I'm going to look like I'm going to
fight in a title fight and you go down
there, you skip rope.
I'm going to get abs.
You're doing all the fucking
shit in two days in, you know,
after two days you get tired. All right?
And that's where you need the
discipline to get up and go over there.
Even though you don't want to. You know,
people who've written
Oscar when he scripts,
I bet they don't like fucking
doing it on, on a certain level,
but they keep going. So I would just
tell you to keep fucking going. Anyways,
let me read the rest of this
drum overly dramatic shit.
I've lost all faith in the world.
Have nothing to fight for anymore.
I respect you.
Go Fuck yourself attitude and want and
want to know what you did to finally pick
yourself up from your dark
inflicted depression. Uh, sorry.
It's not the funniest emails, but I could
really do with you guys. I know, dude,
I'm fucking with you. I know you going
through some shit. So I, here we go.
I'm going to help you out here.
Uh, first thing I would do,
get rid of the KFC and
wet wipes. All right?
If you're already kind of a
depressed dude, if you eat bad food,
that's just going add, cause I, I'm
just speaking personally. Once again,
not a licensed guy here in case you
throw yourself off the fucking roof.
All right? Um, yeah. Number one,
this is what I do. Go out and get
something healthy to eat. You know,
drink some water. Okay?
Get eight hours sleep.
Wake up and need something healthy.
Then go to the grocery store when you
full and go buy a bunch of healthy shit.
Okay? Chop up the veggies,
chop up the lettuce,
get a fucking salad already made in there
so you don't have to think about it.
All right, cook up some fucking
chicken. Chop that shit up.
Make some chicken salad.
You got that in there to get yourself
some fucking lunch fried and get yourself
some real bread from a fucking
bakery. Start with that bullshit.
You start eating right and
then just start working out.
You're automatically gonna feel good about
yourself and fucking stick with that.
As far as that other shit goes.
Dude, you're 24 years old. All right.
I started comedy when I was 24 you sound
like you've already been doing it and
quit, so you're ahead of where
where I was at at your age,
so there's no reason to be
depressed. All right. Um,
this is how I got beyond my depression
was I just started observing it.
I looked at it as a spectator rather
than feeling a thought and just accepting
it and then being dragged to the
bottom of the fucking ocean with it.
I just started to pay attention.
I just sat there and listened
to what my brain was telling me,
and it was a bunch of negative, oh my God,
I'm going to fail and I have to go back
and move in with my parents and they're
going to die.
I'm going to be able to afford to pay
for the house and then I'm gonna be
homeless and then I'm just
going to die. And, uh, you know,
nothing's ever gonna work
out for me. You know,
those were the thoughts I was having.
So I just sat back and observed
them and I just started going,
I don't want to think that. I want
to think that. And I would just,
as I felt them coming, I would just
replace it with like a positive thought.
I know this is really corny and
simple, but I kinda started doing that.
And the more I did that because it
didn't quite work as to what actually did
work in the beginning at all. But like
I just kept doing it more and more,
and then I just became conscious of when
my brain was going in that direction.
And, um, working out
helps me eating right.
Helps me going down to a comedy
club, telling jokes helps me out,
play in drums, wrestling
with my dog, you know,
taking Nia out to dinner. Just go do
something. Like, it's just a choice,
you know, July 30th. So
only gonna happen once.
So am I gonna fucking be a miserable
cunt on this or I said July 30th,
2012 is only gonna happen once. It's
just, it's just a fucking choice dude.
So you know, if what you're
dealing with this clinical,
then it's obviously way beyond
me, so I don't need, you know,
and then I'll have to fucking
apologize like Fred Willard.
Okay.
Um,
I'm sorry that you didn't
go to a psychiatrist and
you went to a hacky comedian
instead. Evidently that's my fault.
[inaudible] fuck you me these bad thoughts
to this place
because
[inaudible].
Um, all right. Why don't
we end with this segment?
I'm sure I can do another 10 minutes on
this to give you at least 45 minutes for
the week. Let's end with
this. This segment. Oh Jesus.
Which is really taking
on a life of its own.
I thought it was going to
die, but it is somehow risen.
Okay.
Um, okay. Here we go.
And get ready for bill is the dumbest
person on the planet. All right, Bill,
for what it's worth,
I think you're fucking crazy and
irresponsible explanation point.
I can ever say the x Scullin x skull.
Exclaim exclamation. There we go.
Exclamation point.
I just want to let you know that those
words that you kind of know how to say,
but you just sort of fly through them.
Escalation point a what kind of
person talks about God like that.
And I love this shit. This is
what they all do. You should.
And I believe deep down inside you
are, be ashamed of yourself. Dude.
This is what I love about these fucking
maniacs is they're so wrapped up into
what they believe that they listen to,
how much this person just keeps fucking
including other invisible people.
And then superimposing what he
believes into what you know he thinks.
I truly believe,
because he's so wrapped up in his own
fucking world that he can't possibly even
fathom that somebody has a difference
of opinion on this subject. So he goes,
uh, you should, and I believe deep down
inside you are, be ashamed of yourself.
Dude, are your mom and dad's still alive?
What exactly does that
have to do with any,
your shtick with respect to God
is hurtful, offensive, offensive.
And despicable. I'm in three things
that always has to be three things.
It can't be hurtful and despicable
or offensive and hurtful.
It has to be hurtful,
offensive and despicable.
Just like comedy has
to come in threes. Um,
how difficult it must be to spew
hatred and vulgarities for shock value.
Laughs, no talent in that my friend.
That's the classic place that
people go. Um, whenever you,
whenever you,
this is the classic guy where everything
is funny until it comes around to the
subject that they take seriously
100% and no one can even joke it,
joke about it or even
questioned it on any level.
And then they always say that you're
just doing it for shock because they find
it shocking. It's like really my views
on women, women haven't been, you know,
that didn't offend you. All this shit
that I've said over the two fucking years,
none of that is offended you and
Al of a sudden this does anyway,
so he goes enjoy your success air quotes
and all the money you are making on the
backs of hardworking, decent people
that understand what it means to follow.
The rules and be the best they can be
without putting other people and god down.
The rest of us are watching
and we are not laughing.
Dude. How many people are
in your bedroom as you're,
do you have a group podcast listening
party every week. All right,
let's get back to that. Oh,
evidently I am making a money on the
backs of hardworking, decent people.
So let me get this straight
because I'm standing on a stage.
Evidently what I'm doing is not hard work.
And if people are sitting in the audience
automatically, they're all decent,
hardworking people. And not only that,
I'm making money on the backs of them,
really do I have some sort of
comedy sweatshop like you know,
of comedy factory was sweatshop
Labor. What I do is actually,
uh, takes advantage of no
one. I stand on a stage and I,
I tell jokes and if you
like what I say you,
you sit and listen and if
you don't, you walk out
right where, where, you know, and I love
how just because you're in the crowd,
that means you're a decent human being.
Do you know the amount of fucking
freaks and scumbags that come up to me?
This is what I found at a comedy show
for the most part, decent people.
They leave after the show.
I didn't want to bug them and then they
walk out and then mania x come up to me.
You know, let's do some Jaeger and they
fucking spit in your face and shit.
You know, believe me. All right? But
I know I made fun of God. So now, uh,
you know,
now all of a sudden I'm now all of a
sudden you want to talk about people
making, making money off of
decent, hardworking people.
Take a look at fucking
organized religion. All right?
Those guys will make those
guys who live in pretty good,
scaring the fucking shit out of
you. Every God damn week. All right?
And I'm entitled to an opinion and I
never was cramming my opinion down your
throat. I wasn't okay.
You believe in what you believe
in and I 100% respect that,
but I have the right to
question it. You know?
And you shouldn't find it shocking
that I question it. You should.
Shouldn't you just be what Jesus would
do when Jesus just started praying for
me. Anyways, let's, let's continue
this just in case you're interested.
I was raised Catholic,
married and raised my children Catholic
and definitely have my doubts about the
whole organized religion thing.
Great. So you agree with me?
Not even sure that I
believe in God. Once again,
there's another appoint
that we, that we agree on.
I lost my father three years ago and never
would have uttered these words in his
presence. Neither would I.
What am I voice go up. So
dude, I did it on a podcast. All right,
I'm sorry your father passed away.
But you know that has
nothing to do with me.
Do you understand what you're doing here?
Now all of a sudden you're making it
seem like I'm walking in with my Mr
microphone into the intensive care
saying there's no god, you know,
whispering into somebody's ear in a
coma. You just go into the ground.
We're all like, dear, I'm not doing that.
I'm doing a podcast and I'm
fucking around. Alright,
if you want to take it seriously,
that's your problem. Okay.
And if you want to bring up your father
passing away as some way to try to guilt
me and to feeling like, I mean, you
know what I'm saying? In a hateful,
hurtful fucking way. Dude,
those are all your issues.
They have nothing to do
with me. All right? 10.
He goes on to say that his dad believed
that there is something out there
responsible for all the
beauty in the world, uh,
in our world and for our lives as human
beings. I don't even disagree with that.
I just know human beings have no idea
what it is until they fucking die.
So I'm not going to sit there and listen
to another human being who tries to
scare the shit out of me and who's living
in a fucking palace telling me that if
I become rich, I'm not going to heaven.
I'm not out of my mind to think
that that reeks of a fucking scam.
The same way late at night when they
have those fucking gold coins that
evidently are with 50 bucks
in this selling them for
1999 that that doesn't reek
of a scam. Somebody actually sent me a
a, an email. Of course I didn't save it.
Evidently it's sprayed with like a
dollar something worth of gold. Okay,
so they're making, what
is that? A 2000% profit.
All right. Believe it or not,
just because you're walking around talking
about religion in the afterlife and
and doing unto others and
you're talking this great game,
it doesn't mean that you
can't be full of shit.
All right?
Okay, and I'm not saying that I'm right
about what I feel, but this is just,
it reeks of, of, of, of a scam.
I really believe that there is some sort
of thing out there and I wouldn't be
surprised if there is
something after this.
I wouldn't be surprised if you just go
into the ground and you decay and you
give life to the next fucking thing.
I wouldn't be surprised if earth is
punishment for something that I did in a,
in a different solar system. That's
another thing about religion. Um,
forget about the dinosaurs is it
doesn't even bring up space. Okay.
Let's say there is this all
powerful beauty being. Okay, okay.
And I'm just trying to
question this right now.
So I'm not trying to be shocking
or I'm just questioning this.
Let's say there is this all powerful
being being, they're created,
the everything that there is.
Okay. The entire solar system,
why would you do all of that and just put
people on this one planet that's like,
you created an n a, you
built this house that has
an infinity basically amount of rooms,
bedrooms and you just put everybody,
you're only using one room in the house.
It doesn't make any
fucking sense whatsoever.
And that's one thing about Scientology
for as much shit as people give
Scientology, at least it has the
brains to incorporate outer space.
You know,
I don't know if that's a really good
point or if that's really fucking stupid,
but you know, I don't fucking
know. So anyways. Yeah. Dude,
I wasn't trying to offend you
or anything that you fucking,
I was just trying to be funny and I'm
just fucking around and if you want to
take this shit seriously, that is
totally your fucking choice. Um,
you know, that's it. All right. I'm
fucking done with that. All right,
let's move on to the next
person trashing me. Um,
oh, what the fuck? Where the fuck is it?
A Jesus Christ? I think I
only bodily put one of them.
I thought I had another one. I'm
really just organized this week.
That's cause you don't have Jesus
in your life. You don't have Jason,
another guy said, I love how you
pick on, on, uh, on a, on a, uh,
a punching bag of religion,
basically saying like,
it's very easy to make fun of Christians,
but I don't dare make fun of Muslims
because if you make fun of them, Oh Shit,
look what's going to
happen. You know? And,
which I thought was fucking hilarious
because the person was sitting there
talking about how insensitive I am. And
that basically, in a roundabout way,
we're alluding to the fact that people
who are Muslim means that you're, uh,
you're a fucking, uh, uh, you
know, you're going to blow up.
Like they're all gonna blow up planes
and that type of shit. You know,
I went to a wedding one time,
this girl was Pakistani and
they actually address that,
that what they fucking hated
was that all, you know,
Christians thought that all of them just
wanted to walk around blowing up shit.
And, uh,
and I also thought it was funny that this
guy's fucking sitting there suggesting
that, uh, people just
because they're Christian,
that they're peaceful when you know,
what is it once every 18 months,
some Jesus freaks fucking kills an doctor.
That's pretty much par for the
course, isn't it? Um, no, and it's,
it's not safe to make fun of
Jesus freaks. It really isn't.
It really fucking isn't.
And I think Bill Maher is out of his
fucking mind to say what he says in like,
or actually has balls the size of the
Grand Canyon to say what the fuck he says
and then just walk out in Wade
into those people and just,
I would never do that shit anyways.
And I got to admit the level with which
that people take this shit seriously.
It actually kind of creeps me out to
continue talking about this shit. So a,
this might be the last fucking week
of it because I've definitely made my
fucking points and at this point we're
just going to go around in circles and
I'm just going to piss people off. So, uh,
let's move onto this last guy. What
she brought up some great points. Um,
all right, set a bunch of Nice
stuff and then he said, all right,
enough with the Dick
Sucking. I was gonna try,
I was going to criticize religion,
but to describe those belief is,
is to mock them there. And you know
what dude? That's what I learned. Um,
yeah, if you describe them, then
you start making fun of them.
And then everybody gets mad, or as you're
saying, they're just so ridiculous.
You just have to, you know. Anyways,
let's fly ahead here. Yeah. He said,
you mentioned needing a code in the
absence of religion to live by. Um,
I'm not sure how much, um, of the,
I don't read things as a Shtick,
but I recommend an excellent text used
in an intro to Undergrad and Undergrad
ethics course called the elements
of moral philosophy by James.
I don't know if that's
Raquel's or Rachael's. Um,
everybody goes on and on about Jesus,
but Socrates who define morality
as how we ought to live,
let a compelling life, as you
probably know. Actually, I don't,
I just know him as a party reference.
Um, what are you fucking Socrates,
you know,
that's one of those references that
even morons can use and get away with.
And I'm sad to say I'm one
of those people. Um, he said,
I didn't know this shit. He was
found guilty of corrupting the youth.
He thought Zeus, Venus, Aries,
et Cetera, smacked of bullshit.
All right, think about that. Right?
They're corrupting the youth now.
Every I Christians, Muslims, and
everybody today would say that. Yeah,
that is bullshit. That those people do
not exist because now we've evolved to,
there's only one God.
There's only one bank.
There's one world power. Um, and
let's see, and his punishment,
he was forced to take his own
life by drinking hemlock poison.
Once again another death because
of organized religion. You know,
these Jesus freaks, these, these
people who are into fucking, I didn't,
don't want the reason why
I don't make fun of, uh,
the Muslim religion is really because
I don't know anything about it.
And the reason why I make fun of
Christianity's because that's what I was
brought up. And those are
the stories that, that I,
that I hear and all I know about
Muslims is basically, uh, you know,
the couple of wars with Iraq.
So I basically don't know shit.
I just think what you,
you've wrapped your wrap your women up
in bounty paper towels and then cut their
clips off. And am I wrong?
Am I wrong on that one?
Either they're not allowed to show
their fucking songs because, uh,
you're going to get an erection.
And because you wear that bed sheet,
everybody's gonna fucking see it.
I, I don't really think about it,
but I would definitely make fun of it if
I knew something about it, but I don't.
All right.
And I reserve the right to make fun of
the fuck a religion that I was brought
up. And, um, so anyways, he says, um,
Socrates was a humble man,
famously announcing all I
know is my ignorance. Um,
he sought I the one that I love people
who would take that at face value. See,
he shatty was you fucking moron,
right? Yeah. Right. Yeah. You know,
Jesus is the solution. Um,
he sought answers to questions where
his religions prohibits questioning
answers.
Yeah.
Oh, fucking brilliant. And
this guy's really smart.
You should do a podcast instead of me.
I'm a fucking idiot. Listen to that.
He sought answers to questions,
whereas religion prohibits
questioning answers.
And if anything fucking proves that
it's the 50 emails I got this week.
I like how I'm actually asking,
like I'm questioning religion on
any sort of intelligent level. Um,
I think actually I think I am just cause
I say cut and fuck doesn't mean I'm not
, uh, bringing up some good questions.
All right. Let's finish this for, uh,
for Socrates. The unexamined
life is not worth living. Uh,
his sentiments on marriage and
nagging women are remarkably markably,
similar to your own, so
underrated. Socrates, overrated.
Jesus. Uh,
okay.
Yeah, that, that's, you know,
that's, that is the one thing,
and I'm not being a dick here that
I don't understand about people who,
like I respect people who, who, you
know, are raised in religion or,
or find a religion that speaks to them
and that they decide to commit their
lives to what? And what I
don't understand is you don't,
it brings you this piece, right?
Am I wrong there? All right.
So it brings you this piece.
But then if anybody questions
that belief that you have,
how quickly it turns violent,
like the amount of people who died because
they questioned these a holy people,
it's this,
you don't find that fucking like
hilarious and ridiculous on any level
like this sitting there calling
the other person, that devil,
because they're questioning their beliefs
and they're saying that that other
person is going to hell.
And then they turn around and kill the
person because they don't believe in the
holy pure way that they live
their life. I mean, I just,
I can't get behind that.
Okay.
I can't get behind that the
same way. Is that the same way?
It's just because you're a red sox fan.
You can't recognize the talent of Derek
Jeter and I gotta be like two full
cuvees you fig now he's the shit.
And I was fucking no. Why? Why do I
continue with this shit? Um, I don't know.
I don't fucking know. Anyways, that's the
podcast for this week. And once again,
I'm not disrespecting
your religions. Okay?
But this is my podcast and when I
bring shit up, I fucking go off on it.
And I,
and I definitely go over the top
saying that somebody was pent.
Playing the upright bass with Jesus's
Juggler is fucking hilarious because it's
over the top. And I believe the
God in my world thinks it's funny.
Yeah,
he's God. Why would he be
intimidated? I bet another thing too,
I don't understand why God
would make all this stuff. Okay.
And then just be so doe angry
all the time. Jesus Christ here.
I'd gone back in and again, I got a lot
of questions. Fuck you. It's by podcast.
I don't know. That's
why I don't understand.
Okay.
You know, I is, it is more
like, you know, when you,
when you build a bookshelf
and you, you know,
stand back and Meyer on your work and
then it falls down on the floor and you're
like God damn fucking piece of Shit and
you start blaming the bookshelf even
though you made it, you're the
one who put it up there, you know?
Yeah.
I guess technically God didn't make a,
he didn't make titty bars. I
guess those are manmade, but a,
you know the broad cinema ma or are wow,
I'm really fucking, I was just gonna
say maiden. His image isn't that,
isn't that what you guys say? They
found a devil. That's the devil.
They got the devil in them. Um, all
right. Whatever. All I'm saying is,
cause it really got serious this week,
people, people really got fucking,
they took it a little too seriously.
All right, so back the fuck off.
Stop taking it so God damn
seriously. And you know,
why don't you actually practice what your
preacher preaches and why don't you go
pray for me? Why don't you do that
instead of coming on here telling me,
you know, giving me your wrath. Isn't
that one of the seven deadly sins?
You fucking maniacs.
You just as fucked up as I am and
you don't know shit either. Right?
All right. I'm sorry. God
bless all of you. Okay.
I hope you find what works for you
and a seriously. If I'm bugging you,
don't listen to the podcast. God
knows I'm not making any money off it.
I don't give a fuck. That's it. You
guys all have a great weekend. Uh,
I tell you where I was
going to be this week,
but I'm worried some Jesus freak is
going to show up. So a, that's it.
That's it. Have a great week. I'll
talk to you next Monday. Hopefully.
[inaudible] [inaudible] it
show at smart
smiles for much.
It's
g,
so
t.
Okay.